Alger Hiss of Cuban undertones a game
graphic so graphics missions and what
else
[Music]
awesome and who is this fine gentleman
and around I'm president of world first
games and I do all the programming parts
so how's character moves and stuff like
that and gameplay and stuff like that
awesome awesome alright we just came out
of seeing Streets of Rage it looks
absolutely fantastic it is literally you
guys nailed in my opinion the essence of
what the game is from a nostalgic
standpoint from a music standpoint so
tell us about your inspiration what made
you guys do a new Streets of Rage
basically we wanted you to make that
grid franchise leave again and this is a
big part of my childhood but a part of a
childhood of many people like yourself
interstates it was very big but in
friends as well and after wounded boy I
was thinking of what we could do next
and Streets of Rage was one of my
cherished ok
oh it's beloved I made a presentation I
went to cigar
didn't expect anything because this is
such a massive laser absolute absolutely
but some point they said yes Wow here we
are making the game show
Wow it looks fantastic now another thing
that's really cool is that uh that
cel-shaded art style right it's very
clean it's almost like a little bit of
the old but a lot of the new so tell us
about the art style and everything kind
of leading up to the Sega pitch so when
I started drawing I drew what I wanted
to see on screen and what what I think
is best for the game at the end of the
day a lot of people want something
different
people want picks it out people wants
really I think a gadget so um as far as
like I know it we're very early I know I
know we're very early as far as
platforms and all that thing and
Counting what up can you say how far we
are in development with the game it's
sounding we you have some remixes but
classic streets are AFA there were some
remixes are those gonna kind of hold on
in the game because I'm hoping
be generous in terms of content we
really want to not disappoint in term of
playable characters and also that here
it's just an idea of what the game will
be - there will be more of course - but
we're not ready to announce any Regas
release date or something capture on
that so currently right now we have two
of the fan favorites where I believe
it's blaze and Axel right those are the
two that we have right now and we we
were hoping down the road that maybe
some more fan favorites that are missing
a little guys skate remember him and I
believe the big guy Adam there's a lot
of Streets of Rage characters there's a
lot of great characters in sweet refrig
know we want to do our best to please
everyone write you cards right and you
need also to bring something new to the
table absolutely that's the point we're
gonna try to be generous right with the
fans and new players and new players
we're gonna try to have something
that's awesome so you doing up you gonna
do a little bit of both like it maybe a
little bit of old but some new as well
[Laughter]
so let's talk about basic gameplay
mechanics one thing about Streets of
Rage it's one of a cooperative dream you
can work with your teammate you can do
moves you can bounce off each other
those kind of things I saw a lot of that
in the game currently right but we also
saw new things you know like this
special meter all these like really cool
new mechanics like can you talk about
any of the just the new mechanics added
in addition to the core gameplay or
feature age the main new mechanics are
that now when you do special it's not a
punishment anymore before you lost your
life now yes there's a way to regain
life so that's one of the first thing we
change but we also add a new move you
can do specials in the air even weapons
right yeah it comes back wow that is
awesome and also there is a new star
moves annual to remove so you pick up
stars in the stage and with the press of
two buttons you only release your angel
is arranged so I'm not getting nowhere
early I know it's still things are being
developed you know but we're trying to
go our see love with the level design
you know any ballpark figure maybe about
levels about how about length of
gameplay hours or maybe levels we come
to
we we know that beat em up games tends
to be quite short in general yeah
and we try to do a voice I have
something more generous and it's gonna
be in the story the story is going to
bring you to places awesome we try to
bring by variety with with a level
design which uses our so car coming
there's a ramp and traps and stuff like
that so it's really about a reason
observe all of that if you look at the
car that is crushing of the wall this is
actually in the original game design
talking to do that but due to time
constraints or trained or technical
limitation that is awesome and look we
cannot wait yeah - before we get there
all yet so again so 2 to 4 players as
far as the cooperative aspect or we we
stuck at 2 or could there be more okay
there's a possibility of more than 200
there's a possible man absolutely now
last thing I want to talk about his arm
bosses at the end of this we got to see
a very cool boss Lauren alder himself
made it there he was fantastic great
Streets of Rage play he's a veteran he's
playing solo but um I was gonna say like
I noticed some really cool boss design
right and um I want to know if that
obviously that tradition of treats and
rage those great bosses where you have
to kind of figure out mechanics or we're
still getting that kind of essence of
Streets of Rage bosses in it
on the buses now we're gonna try to have
a very good AI program nose and game
designer are working very hard and this
is just a preview what you saw is just a
preview we are far more in the
development thread things in terms of AI
or design nice nice let me tell you
right now the game looks fantastic one
cool thing that we saw it was actually
fighting in a subway car and you were
restricted on jumping you're restricted
in a movement and it looked fantastic we
are so excited man I know you guys don't
have anything to announce you see as far
as day and platform but uh when can we
see maybe possibly the next showing of
streets arrays because the crowd is
hyping the anticipation is high we'll
talk to marketing we don't want to get
him in trouble
look streets are a boy guys we got a
chance to play the Lord's got a chance
playing it is ILP approved we cannot
wait to see where this goes father thank
you guys gentlemen it's been absolute
pleasure man absolute pleasure working
with you guys streets arrays for man you
saw it first